Влад вчиться ходити заново Він втратив
ногу під час боїв за Азовсталь
сложно ступеньки що складно сходи а і
мокра погода
бо мені влучили з авіації було
попередження праці що буде авіаобстріл
усім в укриття а хлопці з мого взводу
мої побратими були на позиціях а не в
окроті
[музика]
на позиции сверху не укрытие Я прийшов
викриття відпочити а коли почув цей
сигнал побіг до них щоб довести Я навіть
не встиг Я почав тікати Бо нам почала
працювати авіація по мені влучили роботу
вибратися з Маріуполя до Запоріжжя
хлопцю допомогли місцеві росіянам на
блокпостах Вони сказали що Влад
поранений цивільний хоча татуювання на
його тілі свідчать що він боєць
батальйону Азов меня замотали
получається здесь мене закутали виходить
ногу теж замотали Вона вся в крові була
Я весь у бинтах був і росіяни не лізли
дивитися вони дивляться є кров чувак
взагалі без ноги лежить в
напівсвідомості
владна військовій службі 17 років сам
родом з Донецька у 2014 році з батьками
перебрався до Маріуполя служив у
добровольчому батальйоні Донбас потім у
морській прикордонслужбі Донецьк
Донецьк мій дім через це я хотів воювати
за Донецьк що повернути його в Україну
бо я не збираюся повертатися туди поки
там є Росія
там жили мої предки вони померли на цій
землі Це моя земля
Ми козаки у нас свої правила розумієте
Ми живемо своїм життям ми хоч дуже різні
Але однакові Ми з самого початку були
добрим народом нам же теж не подобається
воювати Я би хотів спокійно жити в
Україні яка добре розвивається і яку
ніхто не чіпає
згодом хлопець уступив до полку Азов
Влад розповідає Що це було життя про яке
він мріяв підрозділ став його родиною
він тренувався з шостої ранку до самого
вечора біг стрільба тренажерних зал
медицина
підготовка підготовка підготовка і ти
живеш цілими днями у нас була підготовка
підготовка підготовка і ти живеш у
такому мікросвіті де немає алкоголіків
наркоманів немає грубості усі з тобою
вітаються це такий світ у світі Я навіть
коли хворів ходив сам у зал і займався
я розумів що спортом вийде ця хвороба Я
навіть так скажу у мене була відпустка я
жив на базі у відпустці цілий місяць
ходив на тренування на лекції ходив на
тактику і все одно я прокидався о 6-й
ранку і займався так само як і в робочий
час настільки це ідеальна система була
ідеальная такая система можно сказать бы
нині після поранення кількох місяців у
лікарнях Він дуже сход протезист поки що
невдоволений владовим прогресом ти
жахливо ходиш мені всі говорили що ти
тут майже літаєш Красунчик А ти паскудно
ходиш
поки Влад втрачає вагу лікарям треба
коригувати розміри протезу протезисти
нині на вагу золота до цієї клініки з
лютого невпинно надходять пацієнти зараз
худала
стабілізуємо розміри протезу щоб було
все чітко все плотненько і вже тиждень
два Я вважаю щось зробимо постійний
протез і вже буде ганяти нормально після
трьох років в азові Влад поволі звикає
до нової ноги й до Цивільного життя
просто люди начали люди почали жити таке
відчуття наче Не має війни Вони живуть у
своєму світі дім робота дім робота
поїдемо шашлички посмажимо дім робота
шашлички і все п'ють Вони живуть своїм
життям як жили до війни їм просто треба
дати причуханки аби вони зрозуміли що
тут війна
Влад зізнається що мало стежить за
новинами хлопцеві боляче що його
побратими з Азова досі в Росії під
ризиком страти ми готові ми готові були
померти там в Маріуполі кожен Хоч би в
Україні Все було нормально Зеленський
пообіцяв обіцянку не виконав обманув
хлопців Він дав наказ Каже здавайтеся ми
вас обміняємо нічого не відбулося
через розчарування у керівництві держави
Влад замислюється про виїзд за кордон
поки з чим може допомагає побратимам з
Азова плани на майбутнє будує разом з
дружиною подружжя чекає на первістка